do you think that we are alone do you
think life has evolved on other planets
orbiting stars some sort of life I feel
like there has to be life but I suspect
it's so different to us that we don't
recognize it
are we alone in the cosmos no I don't
believe we're alone in the cosmos you
think there's other conscious life
somewhere around other stars I think
that it would be very egotistical of us
to believe that we're the only galaxy
how about are we alone in the cosmos I
think the question of are we alone in
the cosmos speaks to the sight the
psyche saying I'm too alone are we alone
in the cosmos are we alone in the cosmos
wow what a question I think if we're the
only species in this whole experiment of
the universe we have a huge
responsibility they like later [ __ ]
together do you think we're alone in the
cosmos yeah I don't have any like I have
no concrete evidence yeah I think I just
want to believe there's other things oh
yeah does it inspire you to think that
yeah yeah yeah like it'd be so cool the
cosmos absolutely not
I think that the universe would be an
awful waste of space
you think we're alone and I think we're
alone probably I don't see any and
there's no evidence we aren't alone do
you think we're alone in the cosmos oh
I'd be surprised if we were don't you
think it's a lot of hubris to think are
we in a computer simulation so I don't
think we're in a simulation I think that
we are in a neural network where where
the hardware the software and the
simulation output are all one and the
same thing do you think we're in a
computer simulation well I think that
human beings do reproduce their cut have
to reproduce their consciousness all the
time and in that sense
yes do you think this is base reality or
simulation that's a tricky one I rather
like the simulation argument I think
that the the impossibility of
determining empirically whether you're
in a simulation and the fact that
emulations could be iterative right that
a simulated universe can have you know
individuals who create their unfamiliar
universe and so on you know that leads
to the rather attractive conclusion that
were very unlikely to be not a
simulation but you know there are ways
out of that arguments are we at a
computer simulation I think a computer
CIMMYT simulation is an
oversimplification what it really is and
I think we don't fully either we aren't
willing to recognize her Ilyas or we're
afraid to recognize what it really is
but eventually infinite consciousness
experiencing itself you all these
different fractals and the fractals
exist of everything like there's there's
fractal view this fact with me this
fractal of everyone watching the show
and it's all sort of this like infinite
movie that goes on forever do you think
we're in a computer simulation do you
think it's a base reality so there's
something that's like inaccurate and and
about saying that you're even a person
because like we're not when I think
about Who I am
like I think as if I had a trajectory
because I did but like really like I'm
not any of the I'm nothing that I ever
was I am like that's included but like I
am something new right now that I've
never been before and I don't actually
know what I am moment to moment yeah
and I'm only knowing myself in saying
this and in being seen and heard by
y'all so there's something like really
trippy about that and so in that sense
like even myself hood like even the
thing I take to be primary is oh sorry
um do you think we're two computer
simulation no I don't think we're in a
computer simulation I think that's more
of a thought experiment - yeah I think
that I think that that's a great way to
think about things in order
to try to remove your frames do you
think we're in a computer simulation our
relationship to consciousness is a
simulation we're just waking up to the
fact that we we perceive time falsely we
think that time is well not falsely it's
just relative to the dimension of the
age and the dimension of our
relationship to the consciousness do you
think we're in a computer simulation and
so the real important question that I
think we should be asking about the
simulation is less are we in one or not
because we've already said by setting up
the hypothesis that we wouldn't know
even if we were right so are we in it or
not and it's does it change the way you
behave does it actually inform or
instruct the way you act in the world do
you dwell in the world differently if
you think it's just a simulation what
would you say is the most beautiful
thing in the world we don't need to
create these false constructions of who
we are and I think there's beauty and
just a simplicity of being who we are
and we have systems whether it's in a
food system an energy system a political
system a a transportation system that
makes it really challenging for us for a
clownfish and a sea anenome for a lion
on a savannah mmm
to a dog to a mountain gorilla simply to
be who we are
yeah and I think I think the most
beautiful thing is just being who we are
and I think the systems that we build in
this world should be supportive of that
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world I would have to say
and it's a it could be so-called
something of a secular spirituality that
we you know as made up of the things in
the universe birthed by the stars all of
our carbon that we are how the universe
observes itself what do you think the
most beautiful thing in the world oh wow
well I mean what kind of already
touching on it for me the some of the
most beautiful things in the world have
to do with connection and human
experience that
and community and change and growth yeah
he thinks the most beautiful thing in
the world
engaging in kind of dialectic
conversations that you know which
thinking things through and thinking
them through some first principles and
and also with someone that is has an
adversarial attitude to yours what do
you think it's the most beautiful thing
in the world oh man the most beautiful
thing in the world
probably the notion of earned happiness
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
the ability to see beauty itself I think
is beautiful what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world
well well oh my poetry book is love is
the question and the answer and the
power of love when you open those you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world sunrise
why because every time I see the Sun
Rise I realized that there is still life
that is living and it's a new day and
things can change for the better
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world that sense of being
present and noticing what's around you
that for me is the most beautiful thing
you